e voi a chiaro dove andrai in vacanza la
prossima estate non monti direi però che
sia una città d'arte o un ameno luogo
sul mare quasi sicuramente le vostre
caselle email sono pieni di messaggi che
sembrano fatti apposta per voi
e i social networks non sono che un
esempio quello più recente probabilmente
di quella comunicazione che cerca di
essere assolutamente adattata alle
esigenze di ciascuno di noi perché
ognuno di noi vuole sentirsi unico in
ogni momento della propria vita
sicuramente quando abbiamo un impegno
importante vogliamo indossare l'abito
migliore che ci calza a pennello
e su questo gli atelier di moda hanno
fatto sicuramente storia perché la
nostra cinta le nostre spalle e siano
perfette il giorno di un importante
evento più o meno come oggi ciascuno di
noi e anche io faccio il sarto non tanto
quando mi vesto ma sicuramente quando
sto davanti al microscopio perché la mia
idea ma non è soltanto una mia è che
l'offerta che si possa dare ai nostri
pazienti sia specifica per ognuno di
loro è una vecchia idea che
probabilmente quando stiamo male abbiamo
tutti chiara ma soprattutto l'idea di
quest'uomo chris walker un mio paziente
un magnate americano un uomo ricco di
vita e ricco di soldi e ricco di
interessi interessi che improvvisamente
cozzano contro la diagnosi di cancro di
cancro del sangue il mieloma multiplo
una malattia devastante che
progressivamente nonostante le terapie
va avanti una malattia che fino a tre
anni fa si riteneva incurabile e che nei
convegni scientifici rappresentiamo come
delle scale che scendono verso il basso
perché meno del 20 per cento dei
pazienti riescono a raggiungere i 5 anni
di sopravvivenza libera da malattia
chemioterapia tradizionale chemioterapia
e innovative l'idea è che quando arrivi
davanti al medico ricco o povero che tu
sia
ricco di entusiasmo o povero di idee
in ogni caso hai a che fare con la
chemioterapia che rende improvvisamente
grigio la tua vita tutti siamo uguali
davanti alla malattia e la sofferenza
perché quella malattia si cura solo in
un esclusivo modo non perché la scienza
non si è andata avanti non perché
cocktail di farmaci non funzionino
ma perché il modo più semplice per
interrompere delle cellule che
proliferano in maniera non controllata e
intanto far smetterla di proliferare e
realtà chris si chiede e non solo lui
alla seconda ricaduta è possibile sapere
quale terapia sarà efficace e nella mia
malattia laddove l'efficacia non vuol
dire guarigione ma vuol dire garantire
delle risposte
beh in realtà è difficile quando ti
propongono un nuovo farmaco o in
generale un nuovo trial clinico sapere
se farai parte di quel 60 50 80
variabile per cento di pazienti che
risponderanno o 20 30 10 perdenti che
non risponderanno e la legge dei grandi
numeri per probabilità risponderai o
meno ma in realtà non abbiamo molto
chiaro il perché e se doveva chiedere
agli altri due protagonisti di questa
storia i miei due mentori alla george
mason university lens idiota chip petri
coin la risposta è
proviamo studiare non c'è altro modo
quando c'è una domanda più o meno
impegnativo o più o meno difficile se
non studiare e tirare fuori le idee
migliori che abbiamo è la risposta è in
un vetrino come questo in cui isolando
le proteine della malattia della
malattia di quello specifico paziente e
testando le contro farmaci da soli o in
combinazione è possibile sapere o
quantomeno prevedere quale di quei
meccanismi proteici sta alla base delle
cellule che proliferano in maniera non
controllata
così quando ormai chris è un paziente
terminale
veniamo per esempio a scoprire che è il
cortisone il farmaco che fa parte di
tutte le terapie palliative dei tumori
del sangue è esattamente il farmaco che
alimenta le sue cellule refrattarie
proprio perché le sue cellule sono
diventate resistenti abbastanza
intelligenti da vedere il farmaco ea
girarlo mentre c'è una via un po più
banale che viene chiamata via del b raf
che nel suo caso è invece ancora attiva
e allora siamo pronti per andare in
scena siamo pronti cioè a dire non
sappiamo quanto durerà questa scelta e
questa opzione terapeutica ma sappiamo
che l'abito che possiamo tagliare
addosso su di te è uno e non altri cento
magari non renderà eccellente la nostra
esperienza magari non renderà unica la
nostra cena ma quell'abito quella
combinazione di farmaci che quel momento
possono individuare il tallone d'achille
delle cellule della malattia in quel
momento è la scelta vincente dal tono
nelle mie parole capite che chris non è
più con noi però ci lascia sicuramente
due grosse ed elia lasciate a me come
dottorando allora è medico ricercatore
adesso in cui non è tanto individuare la
panacea di tutti i mali quanto capire
perché le cellule che dovrebbero non
proliferare proliferano e quando
proliferano come interromperle la
medicina di precisione che quella che in
parole più o meno semplice ho cercato di
descrivervi non è altro che andare ad
individuare l'errore molecolare e
cercare di correggerlo con uno o più
farmaci
questo potrà avvenire in maniera un po
più lenta in alcuni casi noi siamo
riusciti a sviluppare una tecnica che
con circa 800 dollari e in 3 4 giorni
individua il meccanismo molecolare si
può fare di più certamente si deve fare
di più ed è uno di quei pochi esempi
credo in cui la tecnologia anziché
disumanizzare i nostri contatti i nostri
rapporti non fa altro che farci fare un
passo indietro che il passo della
personalizzazione
dell'individualizzazione che in maniera
un po più ampie anche
l'individualizzazione del rapporto
medico paziente in cui non devi curare
solo l'amara
ho solo il paziente ma la malattia di
quel paziente come tutti i buoni abiti
come vi dicevo prima probabilmente non
basta soltanto l'abito a fare è un
rendere indimenticabile la nostra cena è
importante il contesto ed è importante
capire che la medicina di precisione non
è la scelta del medico nel suo singolo
ambulatorio ma è un lavoro di squadra
proprio perché un lavoro basato su
tecnologie e su metodi innovativi che
devono implicarsi fra loro per il
migliore risultato possibile grazie